اسمحوا لي أن أسألك عن شيء كنت
قد انتقدت ترامب
منذ البداية من الحملة الانتخابية
ولكل من
وجهة نظري الأسباب الصحيحة التي شاهدت بها
زملائك الجمهوريين ، الأشخاص الذين كنت تعرفهم ،
الأشخاص الذين كنت تعمل معهم بشكل
مريح ، رفضوا
إدانته  إنه يعتقد أنك تعلم أنهم سيهربون
بفعلته ، فهم يحصلون على دعمه ،
هل تشعر أن هذه الديناميكية
قد انهارت ، هل يدركون أنه بمعنى
أنهم تسببوا في تشجيعهم على الأقل
لهذه الوحشية للنمو والنمو ،
لقد فعلوا وهذا هو السبب  لم يعد بإمكاني أن
أصف نفسي زميلًا جمهوريًا
كما تعلم أنا لست زميلًا في أي شيء في
الوقت الحالي ، فأنا مجرد مواطن
صوّت للجمهوريين للديمقراطيين
طوال مسيرتي
المهنية والآن أنا فقط أشاهد
بلدي ولست مهتمًا  مع
الأحزاب ولذا فأنا لا أعرف كيف استطاع أن
يجذب كل هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
كان ينبغي أن يعرفوا بشكل أفضل لكنهم
تأثروا بموقفهم
السياسي وكيف لم يرغب أي منهم في تعريض
نفسه لمخاطر سياسية.
لا تقف وتقول
الحقيقة أو تقف وتنتقده
أو تنتقد الآخرين وهذا ما
نحتاجه نحن بحاجة إلى أشخاص يتحدثون
بالحقيقة
ويتذكرون أنهم هنا من أجل
مواطنينا وهم هنا من
أجل بلدنا وهم ليسوا هنا  ببساطة
لإعادة انتخابك مرة أخرى ،
تعال إلى الرجال ، يمكنك أن تجعلها في
الحياة الخاصة إذا لم يتم إعادة انتخابك
ولكننا نحتاج الآن لأن تكون
أمريكيين
حقيقيين يمكننا الوثوق بهم والذين سيقولون الحقيقة
والذين سيتجادلون
على أساس الحقائق و  ليس فقط
الجدل حول أساس الشكل
الأساسي الذي تبدو عليه كما لو كنت قد
قلت
عددًا من الأشياء الإيجابية عن جو
بادين أم ، أخبرنا أكثر قليلاً
كيف تعرفه جيدًا ، ما الذي
يجعلك واثقًا من نفسك عنه.
وشخصيته جيدًا ، لقد عرفنا بعضنا البعض
لضيوفنا ربما 30 40 عامًا
شيء من هذا القبيل وكنا
دائمًا قادرين على التحدث مع بعضنا البعض ،
لقد قمنا أيضًا ببعض الأشياء المثيرة للاهتمام
معًا أعتقد أنها حوالي عام و
نصف قبل ذلك دبليو  لقد أسرعنا طراداتنا في الخروج
من ساحة الخدمة السرية
، وكان لديه طرادات قديمة كانت
لوالده أعيد بناؤها ، كانت رائعة
وكان لديّ طرادات جديدة
عمرها سنتان أو ثلاث سنوات فقط
أعطاني إياها أطفالي وجعلوني أدفع ثمنها
لكن أطفالي أعطوها
لي ولذا في السباق ، يمكن أن أذهب أسرع قليلاً
، وقد
توقفت لأمنح نائب الرئيس بايدن
السبق ، وبمجرد أن بدأ رأسه ،
بدأ الدور
للعودة إلى خط النهاية ، هذا هو
الوقت المناسب  كنت سأضرب الدواسة
وألحق به ، وكان ذلك أحد
تلك الأشياء على الرغم من أنه عندما ألحق
به ،
لم يرغب الجميع في رؤيتي
لمواصلة السير وتجاوزه ،
لذا فقد انقطع جزء الفيديو
و  لطالما
شعرت بخيبة أمل قليلاً لأنهم لم يُظهروا
سباقي بالكامل
ولكن جو وأنا قضيت وقتًا رائعًا في ذلك اليوم ،
طاردته في الشوارع في
طراداتنا وهو مجرد رجل عادي
لكنه أكثر من مجرد رجل عادي.
الرجل الذي كان قائدا هو رجل كان  لأن سياستهم
تعرف
بلدهم وتعرف كيف نلاحق هذه
التحديات التي نواجهها كأمريكيين ،
وما زلنا أمريكيين ، وما زلت
أمريكيًا لأنني دخلت الجيش منذ 60
عامًا ،
أشعر بخيبة أمل مما كنا عليه
في السنوات الأخيرة
لأن هذه ليست أمريكا التي
أعرفها وأحب أمريكا التي
أحبها ، ولا يزال الحب موجودًا ،
علينا فقط التخلص
من بعض الأشياء التي كانت موجودة خلال
السنوات العديدة
الماضية وعلينا أيضًا إعادة إخبارنا  مواطنينا
أن الوقت قد حان لإلقاء نظرة أخرى على
ما تفعله والشيء الآخر الذي
يتعين علينا القيام به
هو إخبار الكونجرس
أنه عليك أن تبدأ في أداء وظيفتك
التي نعتمد عليها  يمكنك مساعدتنا في
العودة إلى المسار الصحيح للتحدث مع
ناخبيك حول هذا الأمر ، فنحن بحاجة
إلى
الكونجرس لبدء القيام بما يفترض أن يفعله المؤتمر
وليس القلق بشأن
إعادة انتخابه في الفصل الدراسي التالي